[Musique]
plus on confinant à vite plus on a des
chances que le confinement soit cours
très clairement on n'est pas plus malin
que les autres
tous les pays qui sont atteints par le
vary en anglais ont connu une résurgence
de l'épidémie gigantesque on a quelques
semaines devant nous plus on confine
râteau plus le confinement sera court et
probablement moins pénible donc oui va
probablement falloir prendre une
décision et ne pas trop tarder à la
prendre
rien n'est exclu à l'heure actuelle mais
il n'y a pas de décision qui a été prise
à l'heure actuelle surtout question de
confinement l'enjeu c'est toujours le
même et les français le sachent bien
l'enjeu c'est d'endiguer la pandémie ce
qu'on demande nous c'est de trouver le
bon équilibre ce bonnet qui sait prendre
les scellés couvet les commerces ouverts
tous les commerces par tous les
commerces un bus incendié en pleine nuit
en israël une manifestation qui dégénère
et des policiers qui chargent à
copenhague au danemark face à la
pandémie
les anti confinement et anti couvre-feu
veulent se faire entendre en europe il
faut qu'on dise aux français voilà c'est
la der des der
cette fois ci c'est le dernier effort
qu'on vous dernière les derniers
comptent exactement c'est la dernière
fois qu'on vous demande un effort encore
un effort parce que nous les autorités
nous allons vous proposer une stratégie
pour en sortir définitivement qui va
falloir apprendre à vivre davantage avec
l'aco vide avec la diversité de ces
variants et donc peut-être qu'on est
parti pour des années on a proposé au
premier ministre de mettre en place une
mission prospective pour être prêts à
avoir des idées d accompagnement des
dispositifs prêt pour aujourd'hui bien
sûr mais aussi juste quand on sortira de
cette période parce que je crois qu'on
va ni les années autant sortir indemne
et les décisions prises ont été des
décisions bien souvent incompréhensibles
contradictoires et qui généralement
arbitraire on décide parce qu'on décide
si nous retrouvons dans la situation
d'être obligé de revivre un confinement
c'est qu'on a raté le reste
dans plusieurs villes des pays bas en
marge des manifestations anti couvre-feu
images tournées ici dans la ville de
eindhoven
dans le sud du pays des véhicules ont
été incendiés
l'institut pasteur jette l'épongé il a
annoncé qu'il arrêtait le développement
de son principal projet de vaccin contre
le vph 19 la raison les premiers essais
ou très qu'il était moins efficace
qu'espéré mais vous garango si vous
n'avez pas il ya des études en ça marche
pas c'est pas si si c'est pas mais c'est
comment vous pouvez dire ça en france
face à la perspective d'un confinement
c'est sur la toile que la contestation
monte avec le hashtag je ne me
retiendrai pas la france est dans une
situation explosive si vous maintenez le
confinement
ça va péter je le sens arriver et ça va
devenir incontrôlable marine le pen
devant emmanuel macron au premier tour
de la présidentielle c'est le résultat
d'un sondage harris interactive
si le scrutin avait lieu évidemment
savoir que vous ferez tout à fait je
suis allé le saluer tout à l'heure c'est
un homme dont j'aime le courage le
syndicaux pourquoi j'espère que tu as
bien et m'a dit faut qu'on soit et quand
les rêves bien boire au cou
prochainement à droite c'est xavier
bertrand qui ferait le meilleur score
avec 16%
c'est quand même quatre points de moins
que françois fillon valérie pécresse
elle ne réalisera que 14% lui dit que
c'est un hasard mais ya pas de hasard
rien que des rendez vous non
écoutez je réussis à lui j'aime bien
voilà
parce que jean luc mélenchon apporter
beaucoup au débat public
même si je n'approuve pas tout ce qu'il
dit à gauche c'est bien c'est tout
simplement la bérézina elle paye cher
ses divisions ses discours inaudible pas
plus du quart de l'électorat au total